hi guys my name is Roman is Roman and
I'm working as a partner development
manager for the Google Play team I am
taking care of partners that are based
in Central Europe and Russia and I am
based in Moscow today I will be talking
about the importance of live operations
in a lifecycle of a mobile product also
later on I will be joined by Stefan
who will be talking about one of the
examples that were kindly shared with us
by his company so let's start first of
all quick round about what's today's
last presentation is going to be about
well first of all I'll try to define
live operations and explain why they
important then I will go through four
examples that were kindly shared with us
by our partners there are some people
present in the room thank you very much
guys and I will wrap up by giving some
recommendations and best practices
actually live operations is a pretty
large field of operations and it's like
marketing it touches to a lot of domains
inside of the video game publishing and
there were a lot of cool examples and
best practices that will already share
shared before so I hope that you will
enjoy the middle part of the
presentation that actually brings more
examples and data to illustrate what we
are saying right so this is sorry
skip the menu part now what I live ops
probably many of you have heard this
definition already right in video gaming
especially nowadays we are talking about
running game as a service we are not at
the point where we were developing a
product and then launching it on the
market and leaving it sitting there now
most of the most successful products
that are available for more in the
mobile sphere or other video gaming
platforms are being operated by
companies right so in this very context
I'm going to talk about strategic
distribution or interactions that you
might have with the
that are aimed to increase their
engagement in some cases monetization
overall is to bring more fun sometimes
they will help you to reduce your churn
because English players are staying
longer obviously or even bring some of
them back right so what are the main
components of life operations when we're
talking live operations we are talking
about customer relations customer
relations includes news posting
interaction on forums interaction on
social networks previously we had some
great examples it also includes sales
and promotions bundles rare items
activation or distribution contests and
tournaments business intelligence
business intelligence in terms of lie of
operation is a very important factor
when talking about mobile gaming
publishing we all know this you know
glamour KPIs like monthly daily active
users retention conversion to players
but business intelligence when it comes
to live operations is your capacity of
measuring the impact of the actions that
you are creating these operations that
you are creating for your place base and
here actually you have to be always in
front of the curve if your product is
growing you need to be proactive and
create activities that will actually
even increase this strength if you think
that you are obviously curved in revenue
or they like your active users is going
down here again you actually have to be
twice more proactive in terms of
creating different activities types of
LiveOps so there are levels that can be
bound to the coded updates generally
called patches in industry light and
they come to hype the importance of the
new modes or story that you introduced
to the game they can also emphasized the
importance of new characters story or
skills or new game mechanics that you
are
targeted they are more bound to player
groups right they depend on seasons on
regions they also depend on the progress
sometimes the 12 players have made in
the game we actually had a very good
example half an hour ago what to the
moments when you think that the players
will turn this is just a small reminder
when you are tailoring your live
operations for local markets you need to
make sure that you think globally
because even the most famous
events that we are all used to celebrate
might a cure and different times of the
year in different countries if we take
the example of Easter or like when the
Christmas is celebrated in Russia you
know and they might not be celebrated in
the same way so here you have to be
quite smart and against think globally
this chart is actually pretty famous for
a special for those that are doing game
development you know that you have to
tailor your life operations depending on
players objectives we all know that
competition between players is one of
the strongest drivers when it comes to
increased player's engagement revenue
because it's competition right but not
everyone right likes direct
confrontation some people like playing a
product but discovering it under a
different way some some people as we
know are givers some people get there
just for the social component because
they want to stay connected with other
users
some people like stories and they're
exploring content so when creating a new
opportunity you have to think about
these types of players as mentioned
several times today we are also here
it's all about business right so when
you are creating a lot of operations you
also have to take your own goals into
consideration right here again we are
talking retention and engagement you
need to make sure that the events that
you create they do not burn for instance
your players base because you are for
instance leaving too much content at the
same time that you monetize
you're placed properly later will
actually have a really cool example of
such a case that you drive your players
to content properly because technically
and normally at when your product is
being risk you are the ones who know
your product in in the best way so you
teach people you dictate them on how to
go through it properly and marketing
marketing here is obviously when you are
collecting or gathering resources inside
your company to rise a hype around the
level that is happening in your product
it's also a good opportunity to acquire
new users so this very occasion should
be used it's also a nice moment to cross
promote your product obviously you have
more than one in your portfolio and the
final step
so when tailoring your live operations
you have to tailor them for the entire
base of your players and by entire we
mean the players that are still to join
your project those that left and
different players that at a different
level of the progress of your game
obviously you have a lot to forget about
the poor place because those are usually
the ones that influence the community in
the best way and promote your product
often so why it is important to run live
operations nowadays because the content
is king and we know that players are
consuming it at a different level so you
need to make sure that through your
interactions or the game mechanics you
are present for the players whenever
they want to interact with your product
it's very important and it's one of the
best ways to keep them engaged because
time is money we all know that right and
sometimes when you on development team
and artists are working on creating new
code and new patch you can come up with
an event that will have the same impact
now it's sometimes even better to keep
your users engaged to show them the best
out of the
one example might be like going through
levels of your game or creating
different tournaments based on
achievements or photo sharing contests
those are pretty let's say cheap and
efficient solutions to bring something
additional new but again again because
their engagement is essential here
featuring war Obot and people get used
total to you and the more efficient you
are the more likely you are to reach
your users when you try to share some
important information about the upcoming
event and the upcoming patch people will
just stay engaged longer because we all
know that the acquisition costs are high
and the product data currently on the
market the top-grossing wants a major so
it's one of the best ways to optimize
your lifetime value it makes you
obviously your traffic acquisition more
efficient players stay longer probably
paying more so it's helping you to save
some money and because we all do
products for people we are creating apps
and even if you are interfacing with the
game through a device
you still like feeling a human presence
of human presence behind this is why
actual live ops are important in fact
it's not about short-term spikes in
revenue or daily active users it's
really about building long long-term
lifetime relations and value with your
players so now I will be going through
some examples that were shared with us
by our partners here we're featuring
work gaming and studio from Belarus
Zeptolab UK madfinger games from czech
republic and creative mobile so Stefan
ruler rule from creating mobile we'll be
talking about the initiative on his own
so first example were gaming a pretty
interesting case it was a live operation
that was created for the entire players
base without creating any code so what
the guys did is that they used a
web-based website to pull the
statistical data from the servers and
organize a competition among all players
where every region was important
represented by different characters so
here you can see a cowboy representing
the North America and a Russian night
with a Russian tank and players were
obviously fighting for different
objectives they news about this contest
were just pushed through wargaming
normal networks and actually what
happened is that just once the news will
were released the number of daily active
users have has instantly increased by 4%
this is without actually any additional
user acquisition which was actually
quite a smart move but besides that by
introducing some smart goals for the
community what were marking wargaming
managed to reach is to increase this
battle intensity by 22% to increase its
in-game purchases by almost twice and to
increase their hard currency which is
gold in this game by 170 percent and
this is just by creating an event and
advertising it through the web page and
their community there is another thing
that pops up to the game and this quite
interesting for analysis it's a tank as
I was saying at the beginning if you
remember I mentioned rare items
activation so this tank was initially
coded and added to the game but pops up
only on rare occasions once requests
people can get it for free or just
before Christmas in December it appears
in a special bundle so whenever this
tank appears it just does massive
results in terms of sales because people
know how this tank is legendary and
sometimes of actually waiting for it
purposely so as you can see here the
number of tanks that are sold within the
first
is increasing by 40% it's the
best-selling tank of all terms derives
30% of revenue for months and it creates
actually of a lot of low paying users
for 5.7 percent of people who bought the
bundle with this tank paid within the
ecosystem for the first time so it's
quite a smart mode this is actually
chart showing the number of sales of
this legendary time tank type 59
comparing to other tanks and they eat 25
one of the most popular and available in
the game the whole time this is actually
quite cool so next example is from
Zeptolab Thank You Lana for giving us
the info those case is actually pretty
interesting because not only they show
the results of some actions that were
performed by the partner but they were
actually done in the context of a be
testing so now you will be seeing on how
different changes of variables bring
different results so this case is when
additional content was added to a
premium chest group a is the control
group so the the content that was
usually available in the game then you
have groups B C and D and actually what
you can see is that it's not the group
that received the most of the premium
content that added the most value to the
players lifetime so this is actually one
of the cases where you have to balance
the content that you deliver properly
another example is a person lot of
personalized offers before the studio
had an offer that was universal for all
players but then they decided to include
the content based on the progress that
the players have already made to the
game and here again we can see that the
mouse that our mouth has increased by
45%
another example this is the cross
promotional factor which I mentioned
this is the installs that are being
driven by cut the rope we all probably
know this game to King of Thieves
so here again amazing results were
reached in terms of conversion to
installs and all the right part over
Syria is still the right part for you
you can see the different examples of
icons that were used for reaching those
objectives and the impact it has the
very last one which I personally like so
if you can see it actually features a
special Android skin that was actually
added to the game and feature it on the
store through a banner so here again a
good moment good initiative and good
idea the question has become the four
four times more popular than other
questions in the game so the first sort
of one percent of place for both users
at least once and 10% of players are
wearing it on daily basis really cool
right
last example on my set before Stefan's
the Stefan comes to the stage a mud
finger thank you for providing the
example guys mark don't you but thank
you hi on the left part of the side it's
not a live operation but is they managed
every very cool example on how the
introduction of the PvP mode changes
games KPIs
so the game was released one year ago it
has already 15 million of installs
worldwide but when this guy's introduced
the PvP mode back in man it actually
increased the number of players that
converted to the mode by 1% and their
people also went up and then we came up
with the team with a first purchase
offer that was adding additional content
to the players who opened PvP and here
you can see actually the results were
also amazing in terms of conversion to
paying users
increase of our poo and the project is
actually doing very well and it's a very
cool game so now it's definite or to
talk about the initiative
please welcome Stefan hello you Amy okay
yeah Thank You Romana and thank you
google for actually hosting a very very
pleasant event I actually had the
opportunity to visit the playtime event
in Berlin but I must say London is like
four times bigger here definitely and
yeah it is even an honor to be mentioned
among all the great great developers a
lot of King of Thieves
I even have that on my phone so if
you're looking for a good game for lots
of fun definitely download that let's
start with a question who knows fatty
web well that's like - that's actually
usually the answer I get in Europe well
that's quickly look who is fatty web
fatty web is an American hip hop artist
who rose to actually lots of publicity
in 2015 he has 1 billion YouTube channel
with like 1 billion views and he has
like songs like trap Queen 679 he works
with David Guetta
with SIA with Drake so definitely lots
of big guys and he's among the top 10
most listened artists on Pandora Spotify
and at the Music and he's even nominated
many times for two Grammy nominations
already multiplet VMA and Billboard
Awards and what actually rose some
interest for us he shares a big passion
for cars ATVs and motorcycles actually
anything what has wheels and so he got
in touch with us with his management and
we started talking about actually doing
something together based on one of our
games and we quickly realized that he's
actually interested in doing more than
just being the icon of the game actually
doing more and providing lots of lots of
support and that actually resulted in
one very nice game trailer which I
wanted to show
you
see you
yeah
okay that worked yeah that was night
relation story so it's like say sister
game of Nitra nation and heavily
story-driven
racing game and we worked with a concept
of real rewards there so we reroute the
storyline to focus on fairy weapon to
screw that's Monti and lots of other
people we added new soundtracks there's
there's music added to the game which
will be first released to the game and
then later to his audience actually we
have the we have lots of merchandise
from them from t-shirts to caps to
hoodies to later even a meet-and-greet
which will be result in a tournament so
and that actually resulted in very very
impressive numbers now we got we had a
launch event in New York together was
very well lots of ISM influences lots of
his friends that actually resulted that
we were among top two searched game
actually trending searches for the ferry
web game our retention went high we got
50 percent retention the first month
skyrocket with the with the rating on
Google Play as well for the review score
and we doubled our revenue so that's
definitely I would say a life up which
worked out for us and here's just a
little bit to see the update before
ferry web and after Franny web but now
many of you will agree that the pool of
celebrities is limited and you don't
want to use I don't know George Clooney
for the next I don't know skydiving app
or something like this so it needs to
stay authentic and there's another way
of working not with celebrities for
working with brands what we did and that
is with our like that's why I said
sister game that's like the flagship
title night donation that's like one big
family and there we started to introduce
more and more brands for life operations
and we started to work with tech speed
wheels that's a German remanufacture BBS
Barbet many many we reach actually out
and these Andrew manufactures they
actually do tournaments which are
already written in the game but on
quarterly results we can actually draw
out a set of real rims so if anyone is
actually in need of real reference car
definitely play a little bit of Nitra
nation and something else what we did
there what I'm really really proud about
is we won Hankook I don't know who knows
Hancock but it's the tire sponsor no
tire spawns it's a tire manufacturer but
we want him then as an official title
sponsor for nitro nation and they are
something I think they are currently
number seven or number six in the world
just quickly behind guys like
Continental Dunlop
Micheline so definitely big names and
what we did with them is event
collaboration so these guys are
regularly going to to college
submissions and quickly before we go
into that I think most of the mobile
game developers can agree with me that
exhibitions for mobile game developers
for example the games come to be present
in the entertainment area is not really
the best deal because you need to
compete with better fifth one watchdogs
to that's you know like people running
into the halls to see that not to see
the next mobile game and that's why we
realized it's actually a good time to do
live ops together with some big brands
on Kali exhibitions so we went to the SM
Auto Show last year together with
Hancock and these are typical South
Korean Hancock girls which are always
using and so we work together with them
we invited some youtubers we had a big
shoulder we were part of the booth and
we actually created video content on
YouTube with the youtubers and hang up
together which reached over a million
views in a couple days so many views
that actually the S Motor Show contacted
us afterwards and told like next time
you come you please tell us so that
definitely worked out and yeah
I actually need to rush through because
Roman wanted to go next
no problem
so the day was quite long I'm not going
to read it everything again
it's just a small stress from the fact
that Google is actually amazing at
offering different services and a lot of
good stuff was mentioned today just as a
reminder when we were talking about
getting additional events into your game
you can you know that you can create
them through our services right and we
have really strong analytics tools data
included in the Google Play Developer
console and is mentioned earlier it's
actually in the very heart of firebase
so we just hope that those tools will
help you guys developing better products
understanding your audience better and
using them achieve for free it's a nice
solution then the points that you have
to consider is again just a kind of wrap
up what is important when it comes to
live ups is obviously knowing what kind
of tools that you have to running live
ops inside your game if you are in the
process of developing a new product you
should certainly make sure that you have
one that you have the possibility to
create a mess based on different players
needs on different seasons on different
regions that you have the possibility to
grant or activate items inside your
product without patching it that you can
unknown what offers are relevant to
different regions and you know what are
the best price points for the people who
are likely to buy something in your game
and that you have also team members that
understand the product and can work with
the community so if there are like four
forget about one slide this is actually
how to increase your chances you know
that from time to time we are contacting
you about some initiatives that we are
launching lime game face or summer deals
it's actually one of the best ways also
to get into it because we actually check
if you guys can adjust your prices
accordingly or according to the sea
of the deal for instance or if the
content that is in your game is relevant
to the kind of first at work rating so
it's just another idea on how to promote
your product better and yeah as I said
these are like four points that are very
important for this presentation is that
please invest into LiveOps back-end
tools and team and it also applies to
the player stats API investing talented
people who do really care and know how
to work and promote your project and
listen to business analytics this is not
a luxury solution this is very helpful
and through the examples you just seen
we in order to it works and actually or
in your daily work you also know that it
works and two important factors as I
said it's also about human interactions
show to your place that they important
to you and not forget about those that
haven't joined the project those who
left it might be people as shown with
other examples that might come back
you